[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain the horror thriller film
called 30 days of night spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
the movie starts with a filthy looking
man dressed in a furry coat staring at a
ship harboring to the shore it's
wintertime in barrow alaska everyone in
the town is preparing for the upcoming
polar night a month-long period where
the sun does not rise it is the last day
before 30 long days of complete darkness
begins barrows sheriffs eben olesen and
billy kitka are examining a pile of
burnt satellite phones in the snow as a
result the town doesn't have access to
communication with the outside world
most people in the town are leaving to
avoid the 30 days of isolation while
others are preparing for it after all
this sounds like child's play after what
we've just been through at a local dog
kennel someone gruesomely stabs all the
dogs to death eben gets informed about
the situation and he agrees to check it
out eben's wife stella works for
alaska's fire department she is in the
town for the day but hasn't told eben
because they're not on good terms
however on her way to catch a flight
home she gets into an accident so she
calls eben for help however eben replies
that he is busy and sends billy instead
at the kennel as eben examines the dead
dogs he notices that the dogs were
stabbed repeatedly and mutilated he then
reassures the owner john reese that they
will find the culprit meanwhile billy
drives stella to the airport as fast as
possible but the flight has already
taken off and the airport is closed she
is now stuck in the town for the next 30
days as well even goes to the police
station where he meets his little
brother jake olison and his grandmother
helen munson who works in the station as
well she informs him about a vandalism
problem at the utilidor as eben reaches
utilidor he meets his friends carter and
wilson he finds out that someone has
destroyed wilson's helicopter eben
quickly realizes that someone is trying
to cut off every means of communication
with the outside world elsewhere the
town's electrical manager gus is busy
working at his station when he hears
noises from outside as he steps outside
to investigate with his torch he is
surrounded by several mysterious figures
he tries to run away but he is attacked
the strangers slowly kill him while
sucking his blood it is then revealed
that the strangers are vampires who plan
to feast on barrow for the next 30 days
the filthy man from the beginning of the
movie is in a diner asking for raw meat
and alcohol when the waitress denies his
requests he tries to attack her eben and
stella are there too as eben tries to
stop the man he gets progressively more
violent so he arrests him even along
with stella then take the man to the
station and lock him up elsewhere three
young refinery workers are walking home
from work as they are on their way home
a vampire suddenly drags one of them
into a dark alley the other two don't
realize what has happened after a few
seconds the bloody body of their friend
is thrown in front of them the girl runs
for her life while the shocked man
stares at his friend's body as he does
we see the vampires behind him back at
the station eben is trying to
interrogate the strange man but he
doesn't speak at all suddenly all the
electronics in the station stop working
even tries to call gus but the phone
doesn't work either the strange man in
the cell tells even to hide because they
are coming however eben dismisses him
right after the town's electricity goes
off eben visits gus's office to inquire
about the electricity when he reaches
there he notices a trail of blood on the
snow outside he then follows the trail
to find gus's head cut off from his body
he immediately gets back to the people
of the town and warns them to stay
inside their homes
john and his wife ali are indoors
cooking dinner when suddenly a vampire
breaks in through the kitchen's glass
window i guess staying inside isn't a
very good tactic the vampire then
snatches ally and runs away that vampire
is all kinds of thirsty jon tries his
best to save his wife and is injured in
the process in the end the vampire takes
her away back at the station the man
attacks jake eben comes in at the right
time and shoots his arm even realizes
that the man knows something about gus's
murder but the man doesn't reveal
anything after that even and stella set
off to look for the murderers themselves
they notice something off in the way and
get out of their car stella sees
something through her binoculars and
tells eben to get back in the car as
they drive away a vampire chases the car
and gets on top of it eben shoots the
vampire but it doesn't affect him stella
somehow manages to drop him off the
vehicle and they escape they then get a
call from the station helen screams for
help on the other end they drive to the
station to see blood splashed everywhere
jake and helen are nowhere to be found
but the stranger is still inside the
cell when asked what happened he replies
that they don't want him and asks even
to kill him a few people gather at the
diner and they discuss that the vampires
don't die when they get shot it is also
revealed that they feed off of blood who
would have thought then we finally see
the faces of the vampires their leader
is named marlow he talks in a foreign
language and orders the others to kill
everyone following the orders the
vampires start killing everyone who
comes in their way even and stella
rushed to the diner from earlier to
investigate jake and the other survivors
are there too however helen was killed
by one of them eben takes everyone to
the attic of a house nearby as the rest
hide he and stella go out to look for
weapons but they are attacked by the
vampires again they flip eben's car and
try to drag stella out right when the
vampires are about to kill stella a
bearded man named brower comes to their
aid and hits the vampires with his
bulldozer eben and stella somehow
managed to get in brower's car and drive
away they drive back to the house and
meet the others in the attic they hear
the screams of people being killed
outside but do not dare to leave eben
advises they can go to the store to get
something to eat after a few days they
plan to stay in the attic for some time
and move to the utilidor when they get a
chance meanwhile marlow walks up to the
stranger in the cell and thanks him for
completing the task he then snaps his
head and kills him back in the attic
they decide to sleep in shifts ration
out their food and plan their next step
later for six days they remain hidden in
the attic on the seventh day they notice
a girl outside screaming for help the
girl is jake's childhood best friend
even realizes that it is a trap when he
sees the vampires on top of the roofs
still he goes outside to save her but
can only watch her being tortured and
eventually killed by the vampires as he
is about to return someone calls his
name and he notices jon hiding in a
corner eben tries to help jon but he
attacks him instead jon has turned into
a vampire because his blood got infected
while he was trying to save his wife jon
tries to bite eben knowing that there is
no other way to save jon even chops his
head off with an axe eben then goes back
to the attic and falls asleep due to
exhaustion there wilson's father who has
dementia tries to run away looking for
his dead wife wilson and stella calm him
down but the old man escapes through a
window when wilson finds out he
immediately runs outside to search for
him despite stella's pleas to stay
inside eben wakes up from all the
commotion suddenly a vampire comes
inside the house and even and stella
hide from him as the vampire is about to
get them wilson's scream distracts him
the vampire finds wilson outside the
house and eventually kills him this
gives eben and stella an opportunity to
go back into the attic 18 days have
passed in the attic they have no food
left and everyone's will to live is
weakening they decide that on the very
next hail storm they will make a run for
the store fortunately on the 19th day a
snowstorm strikes they carefully walk
towards the store when they reach there
they collect food and supplies just then
they see a little girl sucking the blood
out of a dead body the little girl
attacks carter brower stella and eben
get her away from him and jake cuts the
little girl's head off the storm has
already stopped when they are ready to
leave now they are stranded in the store
they decide to go to the utility in the
police station where they can be safe
stella says that the vampires cannot
function in sunlight that is why they
have attacked during the polar night
this reminds jake of a uv light that his
grandmother used to grow plants even
decides to run to his grandmother's
house to distract the vampires and use
the uv light to kill them while others
escape to the utility he then runs out
screaming with an axe the vampires hear
his screams and run after him others run
to the police station to hide in the
utility room elsewhere even starts a
generator in his grandmother's house he
then gets prepared for the vampires with
the uv light the group of vampires
surround the house marlow orders his
girlfriend iris who is also a vampire to
kill eben however as iris breaks through
the window inside the house even shines
the uv ray on her face burning it
completely even then realizes the
vampires are going to turn the generator
off he makes his escape from the back
door all the vampires go after him but
marlow stays with a struggling iris he
then kills her to get rid of the pain
brower then tells ibn that it's his turn
to distract them now he gets into a
bulldozer and attacks the vampires
chasing eben after a small fight he runs
the bulldozer into a building and gets
all the vampires to come inside he then
proceeds to light himself up in an
explosion fortunately eben reaches the
police station safely there he finds out
that carter was bit by a vampire and is
turning into one of them with no other
way out carter suggests even kill him
they both go into a room where eben cuts
his head off only five of them are left
but survival looks possible now it is
the 27th day they have enough food to
survive for the next few days until the
sun rises again suddenly they notice
someone from the house across trying to
send them a signal by flashing a light
even assumes that someone is trapped
there he and stella go to save them they
are shocked to see billy it is revealed
that with no hope left billy killed his
two daughters and wife when he was about
to end his own life his gun stopped
working after berating billy for not
saving his family they cautiously take
him to their hideout but when they reach
there they find out that everyone else
is missing assuming they might have gone
to the utility the trio head there as
well when they are halfway there stella
notices a little girl roaming around in
the snow a vampire is about to attack
her from behind although eben tells her
to ignore the little girl stella can't
stop herself and rushes to help the
vampire then follows them eben tells
stella and billy to run away with the
little girl while he distracts the
vampire all three of them run away in
different directions eben somehow makes
it to the utility but finds stella and
billy missing billy finally reaches the
utility but a vampire gets in as well he
attacks billy and bites him in the neck
after a long struggle the two men
finally kill the vampire by pushing him
into the meat grinder but in the process
billy's hand gets accidentally ripped
off too billy has incredibly bad luck
eben then notices that billy has been
bitten so he reluctantly cuts off his
friend's head with an axe
it is the last night of the 30th day now
if they can survive this night they will
be free tomorrow other people from the
group start celebrating while eben sees
marlow and his fellow vampires gathering
through a window
marlow tells his fellow vampires that
the only reason they have been able to
survive this long is because they don't
leave evidence of their work behind he
then orders them to burn the whole town
to the ground just when eben thinks his
wife is dead she communicates through a
walkie-talkie and informs him that she
is hiding under a car in the snow even
promises her that they will watch the
sunrise together he notices the car but
the vampires have already broken all the
oil pipelines of the town the oil is
slowly filling up the streets and moving
towards the car that stella and the
little girl are hiding under even
realizes there is no way to save her now
if she runs they will kill her if she
stays she will burn the vampires light
the fire and slowly it starts to take
the whole town with it with no options
left he takes some of billy's blood out
through a syringe and injects it into
himself he knows that this will turn him
into a vampire his friends watch
helplessly as he transforms he is now a
threat to others in the group so they
decide to kill him however his brother
jake stops them eben then says his
goodbyes to his brother and goes out to
fight marlow after a long struggle eben
finally manages to kill marlow by
jamming his hand through marlow's head
the other vampires see their leader dead
and run away finally the sun rises and
everyone comes out stella and eben watch
the sun rise together they share one
last kiss which is sweet but seems kind
of risky the story ends when the rays of
the sun fall onto even's body he starts
to burn and eventually dies in stella's
arms
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching